And well, hello everybody. Welcome to another Zoom call.
Got a number of questions to go over and feel free to chat in your questions.
Let's go ahead and get started.
Reminder to look and use the member site.
And now that you can schedule follow up calls.
We can self-schedule on the site or on our website.
And we've actually got one of those prices.
For you. So that.
I'm also invited to look at the blog constantly updated blog posts.
Probably put it up.
I'm the 10 new blog posts a week with videos to help educate everybody.
All right, our first question.
I'm on a desk to dial hatch for gestural capsules and compounded testosterone.
Should I order a Dutch test?
Well, I'm a deferred believer if you're going to.
Literally anything. So you're, you're altering your four boats with these things.
I can't understand why the practitioner would give someone four boats like this without regularly measuring them.
It's, it's no different than if you're getting a thyroid, you know, supplementation of a medication you're taking a, you know, a thyroid medication because you have primary hypothyroidism or because you have Hashimoto's.
There isn't, you know, a good doctor on the planet that is a retesting those thyroid numbers on a regular basis.
Maybe it's only annually if you've had it fairly well balanced for a decade.
But certainly, you know, prior to that, when they first start giving you that, they're probably they should be retesting that every three months and doing a full thyroid panel.
Same thing with other four boats, especially when you're when a woman's cycle changes and if she's in metapause, you know, still you have fluctuations in your hypothalamus pituitary access.
You're still making estrogen and progesterone and amrogens in your adrenal glands, you need to get this tested on a fairly regular basis.
Again, our motto, so you can't measure it, you can't improve it if you're not measuring the status, how do we know where in the right balance, how do we know we're doing the right thing we need to be measuring things.
And that's the idea. I just can't believe that somebody, whoever's whoever is prescribing these, they're not demanding that you get a hormone test is the Dutch test a good hormone test to get done sure it is so get a Dutch complete test done.
There's two on a Rupa store, there's Dutch complete another Dutch plus you don't need the Dutch plus the Dutch complete I think is $300 fairly reasonable order that on our store ahead the genetic testing done.
How can I find out if I was tested for the following genes, the MTHFR, the MCY, the COMT, the MTR, the MTR, I don't know how to read the book I was given.
Well, that's why we have the course. So I do understand that reading your genes can be extremely complicated.
So I try to make as many videos as possible and we put them on the course and remember you have full access of the course as our member.
So go on the read your genes course and you can look at those videos you can see what is going on and what those genes mean.
Yes, if you did a genetic profile with us all these genes were tested and it's hard to know where are they, what category are they in, I don't even know what they are.
Because in your full complete genetic profile, they're categorized not alphabetically, they're categorized based upon function.
So you could just read the full genetic profile if you want, it's very large.
When this person had theirs done, it was probably 200 and some pages, now it's almost 350 pages long, that gets complicated.
That's why I also give you an abbreviated genetic profile called, what do I call it, I think I call it genetic summary.
So the genetic summary is about 18 pages long and I only highlight the genes that you have an issue with so go to your genetic summary and look at that.
And then that's still 18 pages long, so I break it down and give you a genetic action step sheet that's only about two to three pages long.
To address those genes that you need to take action, I will say right off the top, the MTHFR gene with somebody who has cancer, even if you have double allele defects on both genes in that family, there's two genes in the MTHFR gene family.
Even if you had a double allele defect on both those genes, I still wouldn't prescribe a person to take methylfolate if you have cancer really person that has that should that has cancer that should be taking methylfolate or metal clomolamine should be somebody that has elevated comocystine levels.
So if you have normal homocysteine levels, now that's the homocysteine is not a gene, it's in your complete metabolic panel.
So that if your homocysteine levels are within normal range and you have a history of cancer, regardless of whether you have defects on your MTHFR gene or not, you should not be taking ventilated folate.
And nobody should be taking synthetic folate period or what's good.
You can't gene has to do with formal production and your transmitter production, that is in your biopterant pathway, your MTHFR and your MTHR gene is how you create vitamin B12 and utilize vitamin B12.
If you have defects in that pathway, typically recommended for you to be on B12, but if you have a diagnosis of cancer, I typically recommend hydroxyl, comolamine, or the adenosial comolamine, not the methyl comolamine.
So all that information is in those three that whole genetic profile gives you a list of all your gene defects, the genetic action steps is the most summarized one that I gave you.
And of course, if you're still confused and you just want to talk about it, well, just go ahead and self-schedule and appointment with me and we could go over there.
So no problem, I'm more than happy to clarify any questions that anybody has, I'll do the best that I possibly can to schedule a time to go over there.
But also when you get to this self-schedule and your follow-up calls, you need to fill out this form right here.
But when you self-schedule, you click on that, you'll have the option to self-schedule a Zoom call or just to schedule a phone call.
Why would I want to do a Zoom call? If you're going over labs, if you want me to go over your labs, or go over your genetics, then you want to make it a Zoom call because then I can share my screen and I can easily play to see this.
This is what this means and I can pull up documents and share different things and make it a better educational call.
If it's just to talk about, you know, your play it or something like that, then you could just make it a phone call.
Okay, question pertaining to this, I have high almost 16 and have been taking methyl B12 for almost three months and slowly coming down.
What exactly is the risk of taking methyl B12 if you have cancer?
So methyl groups do several things in your body. One of the things that methyl groups do is that they silence genes and we don't want access methyl groups with somebody that has cancer because you could turn off to the presser genes.
There are other risks of taking excess methyl groups and by excess methyl groups, that would be somebody who's taking, you know, a fairly medium to high dose methyl folate and taking methyl comolamine because their practitioner, you know, heard about the MTHRG.
Usually that's the case or they read something on Instagram or Facebook about the MTHRG is the cause of all disease, which is total nonsense.
There's a lot of nonsense out there about the MTHRG, more nonsense than any genetic, any gene in genetic test because there's just so many practitioners who.
I don't know how to say it nicely, but don't understand the whole big picture of genes and the readily prescribed methyl folate and the methyl comolamine with somebody thinking that oh, you have an MTHRG defect, well, you just need to get on some methyl groups so that they put people in fairly high dose methyl groups of eight times one to five grams of methyl folate.
The issue with that is that it's even worse than just the cancer piece it's even if you don't have cancer, if you have defects in the biopterant pathway, then you it pushes that pathway really hard so it really can change your brain neuro chemistry and it can cause, you know, excess rage and excess.
OCD issues, especially if you also have those biopterant pathway defects defects on your double lead pathway or serotonin pathway or your dad pathway making glutamates and it can cause a lot of emotional instability.
So, I can't tell you how many people that I've spoken to, especially whenever a year ago when I was doing a lot of genetic consultations, the people that were put on methyl support because the doctor only knew to read the MTHRG and these people were having serious relationship problems and rage issues and all sorts of problems and it gets very serious.
So, you don't want to do that. Now, when do you go on methyl groups? I really think you only go on methyl groups if, if you have issues with almost 60 levels and have no history of cancer or issues with almost 60 levels and cancer or you have.
So, you look at the rest of the genes. So, you've got to take a 30,000, you know, what view of genetics to really look at all of them together and see how everything works together because for the metabolic stamping, everything does work together.
This is why too much of a good thing can be a bad thing with supplements. You can be pushing pathways if you don't want to push.
Now, certainly somebody who has MTRR defects, you do want to support vitamin B12. The vitamin B12 deficiency goes way beyond just a genetic issue.
A person can have no defects on these pathways and still can have serious B12 absorption problems. But what's the number one cause of that?
Well, a decrease hydrochloric acid production in the stomach, if you're not making hydrochloric acid in the stomach, you're not going to be making intrinsic factor because intrinsic factor production and utilization is dependent upon HCl production.
And intrinsic factor is how you absorb B12 from your food. So, if you're eating foods with B12 in an orbit, if you're taking a B12 supplementation, and you have a decrease in HCl, that's why it's so important to be supported hydrochloric acid in your stomach and be taking hydrochloric acid with your meals.
To, you know, at least your larger meals to support that.
So that you have adequate absorb should be 12 because a lot of people are walking around with fatigue.
From academia, and it's actually B12 anemia, they have normal red blood cells, normal RBWs, and every day, and it's really a B12 anemia because of HCl and its relationship with intrinsic factor and its relationship with the ability to absorb B12.
So, you could get on the genetic course and learn more about that as well, and I have some videos regarding that as well.
Okay, is it okay for a cancer patient to take L glutamine for a short period of time?
This person is referring to what I talk about quite frequently that a cancer patient should not be on glutamine supplementation because glutamine is one of the amino acids that can be a direct fuel source for cancer.
However, let's say you're in a fairly good state of remission, but you have major gut issues, and you want to heal the gut.
Can you go on a glutamine supplement for a short period of time?
Yes, you can.
I would say a lower dose glutamine supplement.
Now there are some glutamine so L glutamine is a supplement that is used to help heal the gut.
Why is it used to help heal the gut?
Because glutamine helps stimulate cell reproduction.
Quite readily, let's stimulate cell reproduction.
Well, why would I even want to do that for the fact that cancer?
Well, if your cancer is in remission and it's not a intestinal cancer, let's say it's breast cancer.
But you know, your evident remission, I do really well.
Now I got to heal my gut, I'm having major gut problems.
I say it's okay to take glutamine for a short period of time.
Maybe for a month or maybe two months.
And not take high dose glutamine because there are glutamine supplements that are four or five grams of glutamine.
I think that's way too much.
I think taking less than a gram of glutamine would be your best way to do it.
We have a product called clear GI.
It has one and a half grams glutamine in it.
But it's a powder.
So you don't have to take a whole scoop so that they can have scoop.
You're getting 750 milligrams of glutamine.
It has a really, really good gut healing.
It's a gut healing supplement.
So it's got all these other great supplements that will help heal the gut.
It's a great supplement.
Now, first it has got more active cancer.
Then you go and you're working on trying to heal the gut.
Then you think of something like gastrobed.
That has got less things, but it's got that deglycerized licorice, which is so healing for the gut.
The TR.
Clear GI also has that licorice in it.
But if you want to stay away from glutamine altogether, then you still want to risk it.
Then you go with the gastrobed supplement.
But remember, you've got to start with your healing.
You've got to start from the top down.
Are you chewing your food well?
Do you have HCL issues?
That's the, again, the number one digestive problem.
That's how so many digestive problems start is because of a decrease HCL production.
How does that happen?
Well, it happens because stress kind of because of dietary issues, damaging those cells in the stomach that make HCL.
So you need to support it by adding HCL and digest the enzymes to your diet when you eat.
And, and then it might be necessary to heal the gut.
Now, again, I have multiple videos on HCL and healing the gut and how HCL deficiency.
So often leads to H. Pylora.
If you look back to Pylora, I have videos on that at blog post on that.
So make sure you take a look at that.
Is there a test for cancer?
Family member suspects breast cancer that doesn't involve a biopsy.
So I assume this person doesn't want to do a biopsy.
They suspect breast cancer.
We get the only way to get a legal diagnosis of cancer is to do a biopsy.
So you can't get a legal diagnosis cancer without doing a biopsy.
Even a, even a radiologist who maybe does a scan of somebody.
And, you know, radiology, you learn how to identify pathology.
So you can look at a radiograph, whether it be an X or a CT or MRI.
And you could go, oh, wow, that's osteosarcal.
Wow, that's, you know, pneumonia or that's this.
Technically, a radiologist can't write that they can say it's suspected of this.
So they use terminology like just that it's, it's possibly this.
They can't diagnose, especially cancer, you can't diagnose for the biopsy.
So they can make suggested comments, but that's all they can do.
Even, you know, with ultrasound, same thing with a mammogram, same thing.
So we're talking about for breast cancer itself.
What would be the thing that would be done if you went into your biologist and said,
I have a lump in my breast, could you check this out?
Well, the first thing they would do is a mammogram.
And then after a mammogram, they may do it ultrasound.
And they may do it ultrasound guided biopsy.
And then from that, they'll make decisions of care, because that's what will.
Those are the steps that are going to lead to a cancer diagnosis.
Now, I understand there's a lot of people go, hey, I'm not going down that pathway at all.
I ain't going in there. I just don't want to do that.
Well, that's that person's choice.
And, um, but we can't diagnose cancer without that.
Now, you can get some pretty good ideas.
There's some tests that you could do to get some ideas.
Now, if it's female, you do the female tumor panel, uh, tumor marker panel, male,
a male tumor marker panel, if you suspect a cancer.
Now, certainly if male has elevated PSA, uh, of any considerable value.
You know, it's a pretty good indication that there's something going on.
And you're, you know, typically, but I, um, prosthetic hypertrophy doesn't.
Result in a elevated PSA.
Um, now typically, if a person doesn't have cancer, they typically will not show elevated tumor markers of any kind.
Um, but the problem is, is that two workers are specific to cancer, except PSA to prostate.
Um, and, um, a person can have, you know, very advanced cancer and not show positive any positive tumor markers.
So, um, two workers is not diagnostic of anything.
Even with, uh, a person with, uh, advanced prostate cancer goes in and doesn't PSA.
And it's, let's say it's 250.
Wow. You know, this is fairly advanced prostate cancer.
Um, still, they can't diagnose it as cancer.
You know, your GP may say it, but not from a legal standpoint, get diagnosed until it's biopsy.
And they won't do any treatment, but don't get any biopsy too.
So if you want to follow through with any standards of care treatment, then you have to go down, you know, their pathway and getting biopsy.
If the part, you know, if you're saying and asking this question that they don't want to follow through with any treatment, well, you don't have to get biopsy.
You can do other things like this.
Um, there are, um, what are called ominous sides, uh, uh, uh, complete metamorph panel as well.
Um, if the person has low protein levels, if they, if they're cholesterol levels plummet, let's say they had a, you know, their cholesterol was always in the one diabetes and they went in and got there.
Um, at your physical and their, and their total protein value is low and album is low, globular, this low, and their cholesterol wasn't say 125.
They go, oh, wow, I'm really doing good. The one that's an ominous sign for cancer.
So, um, but again, it doesn't tell you that you do have cancer, you have to follow up that tells you an ominous sign tells you to start digging further.
I'm asking the question a lot.
Uh, now, first and, you know, suspects cancer because of other things you, you know, should definitely do, you know, general blood work up like a CDC, make sure that they don't have anemia and you're dealing with that bite of the cause of that.
And your complete metabolic panel as well to our panels are another thing that you could use to screen.
This is another part of that same question that this person asked, have you ever accepted anyone as a patient to remember without a full diagnosis?
Did the answer yes, but because we don't diagnose and because we don't treat disease.
So we don't, we're not like a clinic that, uh, that treats disease.
Um, uh, and, and, uh, so therefore, we don't, um, uh, that's not what we worry about.
So we still, we still care for a person and make recommendations based upon the cheeks who I'm not based on their diagnosis.
Um, now if we're going to do right program, you know, it's very helpful if we have a diagnosis, so we don't want to program, but even if we have a suspicion of a disease, you can run it.
It's just, it's just like when you use the right for sheet and you have a really bad cold.
Well, you might not go in and get an x-ray to find out whether you have pneumonia.
Um, but you can run the pneumonia blaster program because you have the signs and the symptoms, um, on the disease.
So do you need to go and get a stamped rubber stamp of a disease in order to treat, um, for the signs and the symptoms.
So you could use your brain and go, boy, I have this really bad cold and cough, so I'm going to run this respiratory thing.
I think it's a virus. I'm going to run my viral program. I think it's a bacterial infection. I'm going to run that.
So you can still treat, um, the person that you're treating your body, um, that necessarily treating a named diagnosis.
The question that came in, I'm regretting allowing the doctor to put a tag into my dress tissue. They don't make it sound like you have a choice, but I think to do.
I've heard subsequently that some women have reactions to the medals and the tags.
If I had to do it again, I would not allow a thing for me. It was harmless, but we know how that goes.
Yeah, we don't have necklace. They assured a lot of people that they'd be fine. Go ahead and with COVID and getting red.
We don't have that.
It's really hard to trust the medical profession with all the lives that have about it all the medical professionals who have compromised their integrity the last few years, like never before.
It's very hard to trust them.
Now, personally, I have not heard of a lot of people having serious effects from that tag. However, however, we know.
I mean, maybe a person has passed the stage of cancer. They've recovered. They're doing really well without they're getting headaches.
I want to show them. However, years ago, I had a young woman she was in her twenties came in with serious headaches.
I had tested her with kinesiology and she came up with comfort toxicity.
So I think you, okay, where'd you get this comfort toxicity? So we went through all the possible sources of copper, etc, etc.
And turned out she was oh my gosh, I just had a copper IUD placed a month ago.
And that's when my headaches started.
So she went and had a taken out at her headaches went away after we did some detox on it.
So, you know, the practice of medicine is can be the cause of a lot of disorders that even disease but just, you know,
issues that a person may have signs symptoms that a person could have. So, yeah, what else they don't trust anything.
They do, even though we need them, they're beneficial for all sorts of, you know, crisis intervention, broken legs, etc.
But it's hard to trust.
My granddaughter has issues with her gut. Is this a type of patient that you take?
Yes, it is. So we can still help a person like this. I mean, it would be like anybody else. Go on our website.
Now you can just click over begin here and you'll see schedule down. And this is what all of you can do on the schedule down page.
You'll have the option to schedule an initial consultation or recall case review.
You fill out the intake form and you schedule self schedule. Otherwise, you can call the clinic and talk to us during the week.
And this on the schedule now page on our website. I did make a screenshot of it.
But below here on the page is where you would schedule for a follow up visit. And that's where again, you could choose to do a zoo.
But yeah, no matter what, you know, health condition, the person has, has will still do an initial consultation.
You know, I may, you know, recommend different labs. I may recommend getting a course.
You know, if the person's having gut issues, maybe the detox course, maybe more likely on a immune course that's more complicated.
And so, yeah, we still help people with all sorts of different conditions, even though we don't attract a lot of people with that with different conditions, because our website is all about cancer.
But certainly, we have a lot of relatives and patients as patients slash members. So, yep.
We're going to try to help as many people as we can. Why don't you like the liquid ionic minerals? Some people on Instagram say that they are the best.
Some people on Facebook and Instagram say all sorts of things. So, first of all, don't believe everything you say.
Don't believe everything you hear people say don't believe everything I say.
So, but unless you're given a solid reason. So, let's think about so the liquid ionic minerals.
And we'll also lump into that category poorly chelated minerals like calcium carbonate.
So, liquid ionic minerals and earth minerals. Actually, there's a brand called earth minerals, which is just really pool pool party.
I don't know how to say it nicely on the say it's really stupid because it's because that's not how we're supposed to eat our minerals.
That's not how we're supposed to get minerals. We don't suck on a rock to get our minerals.
You know, so I just put this together. There's minerals in soil. So, you get minerals in soil.
How do you get minerals from the soil into our body? So, there's earth minerals, ionic minerals in the soil in water.
And this is my argument to get people will say, oh, you shouldn't use distilled water or reverse osmosis water because it's dead water. It doesn't have any minerals.
You're not drinking water to get these earth minerals. Those earth minerals are not even good for you. You don't absorb them. They actually take up absorption sites from minerals that you would get from your food.
So, your vegetables and plant animals that eat vegetables, aka cows eat vegetables and they're eating vegetables that have taken minerals run the soil and change them into a double bond, a meal acid key late.
The double bonded amino acid key late mineral is how we then eat minerals. So, we eat our vegetables and we eat our good grass fed beef.
And it has double bonded key lated amino acid key lated minerals that we eat. That's how we're able to absorb minerals and utilize minerals in the cell.
So, not only does it need to be in a double bonded to an amino acid key late to be absorbed through the gut wall, but it needs to be in that form to be absorbed through the cell membrane into the cell in order to be utilized best.
So, you could bond it to different amino acids to get different benefits. And you see that a lot with different magnesium blends, but you're getting your minerals through, they're still double bonded to an amino acid.
And that's that's why I'm against liquid ionic minerals. That's why I'm against poorly key lated minerals like calcium carbonate calcium carbonate is just limestone.
That's an earth bond mineral. You don't get benefit from it. It can damage your gut. And if you do absorb it, the reason why you would absorb it is if you have a leaky gut issue, which most people do.
So, you have a damage gut. So, things get across that shouldn't get across you absorb calcium carbonate. And it will oftentimes be deposited at ligament to sites causing ligament to arthritis.
So, degenerative arthritis leads to that also poorly for poorly telated calcium gets deposited in the arteries causing early ethanol sclerosis. It's just they're just dangerous minerals. I'm totally against the liquid ionic minerals. It just does not it's not how we're supposed to eat our minerals.
So, you either buy minerals that are just food based minerals. So, it's just food based vitamins.
But they're hard to come by. They're not always easily found in a multi mineral complex, because different foods have different minerals.
Or there's two companies one tracks and one called Albion that make these double bonded amino acid keylates and then sell them. They don't have their it'll sell their own vitamin lids. They sell them to good supplement companies.
So, like our clear multiband is a tracks Albion product that is an organic mineral amino acid keylates. So, really, really important.
Okay, question that came in is intermittent fasting always better than spacing your food out through the day.
Same amount of food. Yes, I think you're talking about if you ate three meals a day, you're spacing the food out. You have four hours in between each meal.
What's the benefit of intermittent fasting over that?
It's very, it's very different. So, if you're only eating with it a window of let's say three to six PM every day, you only have a three hour feeding window, you're basically fasting for 21 hours a day.
You get there's lots of different benefits of fasting and I have several blog posts on that.
So, it is much more beneficial to to do it that way to do that high restricted eating slash intermittent fasting.
It's not that you have to do every day and it's not necessarily something you should do every day.
But to do that once to twice three four or five times a week, it can be very beneficial.
My genetic test had 230 pages what new developments make the test now 350 pages. Well, as new genes are researched, they, they have added new genes to the mix.
So understand you're 230 pages that if if I printed the list of your full genetic summary and they would only be a gene for a line instead of all those words that you have in a box of it that make 230 pages, they'd be way over that because they're about a genes that actually are tested are bigger.
So, if I let me do this real quick, so I'll give you an example.
So, the summary that I gave you was at that time that's what was summarized.
So, I will see how many pages your SNP report would be now takes a minute to learn so I'll go on the next question.
I take pure encapsulations, magnesium, citrate, malate for constipation, is that what okay or should I switch to something else when I write out, no, that one's fine.
Here are encapsulations uses out the materials. Have you been following Dr. McCullough's new articles about how doing too much keto or fasting damage or metabolism causes stress via cortisol.
It's like he's done a 180 degree turtle as a vice.
He said it's better for me to get energy from glucose.
Well, you know, you do have to be careful with, you know, anybody who follow it, Dr. McCullough, I love him, you know, nearly he's a great guy, but he jumps on his bandwagon all the time.
And you do have to be careful that, you know, he really pushes different things really hard to sell things, which I don't like that about him.
But I do agree with this point. So I went, he was on the giant bandwagon doing keto and and fast eat all the time for people who are not cancer patients.
So I don't like those bandwings because you know, these aren't good for everybody. And I don't think these diets are good for everybody.
And you see books written on them that everybody should do keto. You know, this is the danger of Instagram and Facebook because somebody who is doing something, let's say they're doing a keto diet.
And they think that everybody should do a keto diet. Not everybody's metabolism is set up to do a keto diet. They can't do a keto diet. It wouldn't be healthy for them.
It's like somebody who goes, who goes to vegan, thinks everybody should go vegan. The truth is, vegan can be a healthy thing for people. And vegan can be the least healthy thing for probably most people.
So now the biggest craves is this carnivore diet. Everybody should only be eating meat. Okay, whenever you have that word only in there, you should already should throw a red flag up in your money.
So you know, I always go back. Okay, what what's the thing that you kind of kind of put things in perspective is God did put us in a garden. We are supposed to be eating vegetables.
But then after the fall, he did give us meat to eat and he did give us grains to eat and he did say that we're supposed to eat seeds and nuts and things.
So to just cross these things off of our list because of some some diet that's going around that some reputable doctor is pushing.
I think it's wrong. You go back to biblical ways of how we're supposed to eat now granted our food has been adulterated and granted our grains have been so scorched and damaged. It's crazy and granted a lot of people have gluten sensitivities and they have antibodies to be added and began peptides and dairy and different dairy peptides and things.
So you do have to address those things because bad is so destroyed our food supply. But God has allowed us to eat everything.
And you know, we have to be in balance with all that we eat now and everything might not be good for everybody.
But it doesn't mean that it's not something that is a bad thing to be doing.
So even a cancer is it okay for a cancer patient to be doing keto or fasting.
You know what I've said about fast eating and I know there's been there's disagreement out there about how long the person should fast if they have cancer and I've said that you probably shouldn't be doing too many fast over 24 hours if you have cancer.
And how long should you be on a keto diet if you have cancer if you have a cancer that would be beneficial for a keto diet, which is typically like the brain cancers.
It's not something you stay on the rest of your life either. So it's it's about that balance.
And you know, I have a long said to you that we think about how food, how we grow food and you know, should we be eating more in season.
Should we be eating apples every day just because apples are good for us. Maybe not.
You know, so you know, we rotate our diet and rotate what we can eat.
Can we use grass fed liver instead of B vitamins? Well, grass fed liver has benefits.
So I think good clean organ meat has a lot of benefits for us.
So yes, I'll think it is. How many B vitamins are in it? I don't I'm not sure. I don't know if you're getting if you're eating grass fed liver just the liver itself.
Is that going to contain enough B vitamins. I don't I don't know either.
And if you're if you're just getting B vitamins because you feel like you should be getting B vitamins, or you're getting you're taking B vitamins because a measure deficiency.
Then you just read if you measure it something, okay, let's say you're measuring homocysteine.
And I don't want to be taking methyl Bs or anything. I just want to eat grass fed liver. Well, then go ahead, try that and measure the homocysteine again.
So if you're doing it because you're trying to do something that's good for you. That's not something you're measuring.
Then you just have to try it.
So we should really be asking you to evaluate our best diet as we go along, then we when we do in cheek swabs. Yes, and most advantage in the diet, they might change during our cancer journey.
Yes, and you know, Dr. Recola obviously is a trade cancer patient, so he's not talking necessarily about keto and fasting and such regarding cancer. He's talking about that in the general public as well.
And that's why I've said, you know, your diet can change because cancer may always be trying to find the fuel source, so you need to try to stay ahead of it as best you can in trying to block that fuel source.
Okay, finally, it's loading your genetic report there young lady, and you said it was 230 pages before. Now it's 334 pages.
So it still took the genes that you did it's that the test that we're doing doesn't test for any more genes, but as data on more genes comes available, well, then they're putting the different categories.
So I mean, there's still research coming out on these genes weekly basis. So as that research is categorized, then you this is categorized as well.
So I can send you this if you want to hear about it.
Okay, any other questions? Are you familiar with the drug, the and for reducing glutamate? Yes, I am familiar with it.
I don't I haven't written anything on it because I can't describe it. So I know there's some, I know I talked to several doctors who do prescribe and they were excited. They thought there was going to make some difference with
especially people who have glutamate driven cancers. I get a drug that side effects too.
And I would think that the side effects with the drug that's going to reduce glutamates can be emotional side effects too because glutamate is a neurotransmitter used in a neurotransmitter throughout the body.
And it's used heavily in the brain as a neurotransmitter. You need glutamate to wake up in the morning, you need glutamate to function and to think and to concentrate glutamate as an excitatory neurotransmitter.
But it's been shown that people that have a little bit excess glutamate defects on their gadgets that produce excess amounts of glutamate from glutamine because glutamate is converted to glutamate is they have been shown to be more intelligent people and people that are more driven and get more things done more successful in life.
But there's a fine balance excess glutamate leads to OCD issues, a lot of people that are successful have some OCD issues, but excess OCD can be a problem. It can be very life damaging.
So I would think that one of the side effects of a drug that's going to reduce glutamate is going to be a loss of drive, a loss of concentration, a loss of mental clarity, things like that.
So with any drug, there's always issues. All right, with that, I will be to do.
Thank you guys all for your prayers and continued support and have any questions feel free to make an appointment as we clarify it on the Zoom call.
All right, bye bye everybody.